[Music]
for decades the process of releasing
Triple A video games has followed a
predictable path next generation engine
we're introducing a new era of
battlefield this has been honored to be
working together with Infinity Ward to
create modern warfare 3 but what if
there was a developer competent enough
to buck that trend no media previews one
minute and 53 seconds to the entire
world
no gigantic marketing campaigns and
absolutely no warning
there's our countdown guys the sit here
ready
let's see what this game is all about
baby 19 18 17 so we're gonna we're gonna
experience it together I'm ready to oh
all these people are about to play this
game and they're bout this up 13 12 11
10 9 8 7
[Music]
[Music]
it's a broad day baby
[Music]
what's up night oh my god oh my god dude
[Music]
oh my god I got all through peach take
eat that [ __ ]
let's go apex legends origins date back
to 2010 when Vince Zampella and Jason
West founded Respawn Entertainment after
a messy breakup with Activision forced
them out of the studio they co-founded
and a multi-billion dollar franchise
they helped create Call of Duty is like
my baby you know I helped create it I
don't want to see it die right you know
I want to make something different I
want to make something you know new and
bring a new game to people so we opened
up the company we had it was just Jason
and I we started the company we didn't
know what the reaction would be you know
some of its based on probably how well
Activision was treating the people and
what they were doing to try to lock them
down and you know you never know what's
gonna happen and for us to get that much
interest was yeah it floored me after
four years of quiet development
respawned came out swinging at e3 eager
to announce what they've been working on
hello everyone it feels really great to
be back on this stage and finally
sharing with you titanfall the team at
respawn has been hard at work pushing
the boundaries of multiplayer gaming
partnered with Microsoft has given us an
amazing opportunity to define what this
generation of gaming has to offer beyond
just Hardware titanfall launched on
March 11th 2014 as a multiplayer only
microsoft exclusive published by EA a
decision that we made to try to take
that the story elements and put them in
kind of weave them in descent into
multiplayer because it was something new
you know it was it was that desire to
really just express ourselves in a
different way buttery smooth gunplay
helped anchor it's wild and kinetic
movement while giant mechs served as
inspiring ultimate abilities
respond presented the world with a brand
new IP wrapped up in all the pomp and
circumstance its lineage is known for
fight all of our sacrifice is bought us
is one day but despite strong sales and
generally favorable reviews there was an
alien quality to titanfall that extended
beyond the space opera themes audiences
didn't quite know how to respond to a
game with no traditional single-player
campaign and a lack of core content I
think if we had tried to do a
single-player campaign back then we
wouldn't have done it as well because we
didn't understand or we didn't have a
good understanding of how to mold those
mechanics into a single-player game that
we got post you know talking photo
unlocking so all this coupled with
shoddy matchmaking
inconsistent performance on console and
a lack of on disc content meant that
titanfall was forgotten as quickly as it
arrived Titan falls problem was that it
didn't have enough juice in its multi
player to keep you coming back over and
over and over again I tied it out you
know after resenting that second time
around they didn't have content or a
plan or announcement of what they're
gonna do to make you want to come back
and keep powering it on for this
when respawn released a trailer for
titanfall 2 in April of 2016 it seemed
like they listened to feedback and made
changes for the better it's a different
story like you don't have to have played
titanfall one to enjoy understand Titan
fry - it's its own contained story and
and everything so and which it was
important for us yes we hopefully will
have a lot of new fans
the sequel included an interesting
single-player story more emphasis on
unique Titan classes and more of
everything people loved about the
originals multiplayer
[Music]
but of course in classic respawn fashion
things weren't easy the month of October
is a historically crowded release window
for videogames so when it was announced
that titanfall 2 would release on
October 28th the community scratched
their heads with many assuming EA was
sending it out to die it's only a damn
shame that EA made the [ __ ] up
decision to release it like a week after
battlefield 1 and just before call of
duty almost dooming it to fewer sales
and less recognition but depending on
what you read and who you listen to the
decision to release titanfall 2 between
EA zone battlefield 1 and Call of Duty
infinite warfare reportedly was respawns
combined the release window with a lack
of marketing and people assuming it was
still a console exclusive and titanfall
2's launch week sales only reached a
quarter of its predecessors through that
same time period two rounds in and the
brash rebel studio was on the ropes and
in need of a win after the release of
titanfall 2 EA bought respawn in 2017
and started development on a third title
in the franchise a is buying respawn
developer of titanfall 1 & 2 and
apparently 3 yes and a as yet to be
named Star Wars game in a deal that is
reportedly worth up to four hundred and
fifty five million dollars but in
watching the Battle Royale genre take
the world by storm
respawn decided to make some changes
when battle royale started to blow up we
recognize that this was a opportunities
is a new genre and it's a chance to
define that space up until this point
the Battle Royale genre had occupied two
popular extremes the gritty military
inspired tactics of pubsey and Call of
Duty black out that rewarded methodical
play and twitchy reflexes
come on you gotta cross off me like that
let's go and fortnight which is well
fortnight oh my god if that respawn were
hyper aware of this and made sure that
their Battle Royale game would land
squarely in the middle straddling
fortnight's quirky over-the-top nature
with the fast and strategic gunplay of
pub G and blackout sprinkled with a dash
of MOBA inspired hero abilities for good
measure and it would be known as apex
legends silence you think you've got
what it takes
and coulis a bakes legends set 30 years
after the events of titanfall to the
world of apex legends is rife with Civil
War and political unrest a
long-forgotten bloodsport is resurrected
and 60 legends drop into kings canyon
scrambling for weapons and resources
before [ __ ] each other up in the name
of glory I can do this I think
let's [ __ ] go dude let's [ __ ] go
33 let me choose Apex follows in the
footsteps of its battle royale peers by
borrowing concepts and twisting them
slightly which uh sure's in a sense of
familiarity just different enough to be
refreshing we play games just like
everybody else and so we were like if
we're gonna do battle royale like we're
really gonna do it right we tried our
version of it right off the bat it
wasn't elisa magic there
the twisted familiarity begins with its
characters and world building the
characters become legends because we
knew very strongly that we didn't want
generic soldier characters respawn took
the concept of a hero shooter black
blizzards overwatch and narrowed it down
to eight unique characters at launch
there's life line the Haitian medic
who's eternal optimism is infectious or
mirages whose charming persona is baked
into his decoy abilities this was just a
lovely time thank you for this the small
but diverse roster makes each character
easy to try out while their abilities
are deep enough to rock a main
class distinction is present as well
gibraltars passive gun shield and
deployable protective dome make him
ideal as a tank while bloodhounds
tracking abilities make him an
interesting offensive support hybrid
they have a very interesting tracking
system which allows you to hunt down
opponents by seeing their recent actions
for the previous 60 seconds and it lets
you play a very aggressive play style
respawn also paid close attention to the
inclusivity of its roster as well
highlighting to women of color in
Bangalore and lifeline as well as
confirming Gibraltar as a gay man and
bloodhound as non-binary utilizing vais
them pronouns respawn baked these
identities into its launch extending a
welcoming hand to those players who've
yet to see themselves represented in a
video game from day one very important
to me that the female characters look
like they belong to this universe and
race in particular embodies a lot of
that for me she's mysterious she can get
up close and personal she can scare the
crap out of you I've got everything you
need
twisting familiar concepts extends to
response take on squad play unlike
fortnight in pub G apex Legends has no
solo or duo drops instead squads of
three drop into king's canyon with a
designated player controlling the
descent WOD play with our legends gives
you this opportunity to define how you
want to play there's lots of meta
choices beginning to match about what
characters you're gonna choose sure you
could peel off from your squad mid
launch but be prepared for constant 3
view 1 scenarios as most squads tend to
stick together
Oh God dude even death isn't constant in
apex if you die your team has 90 seconds
to grab your banner and bring you back
into the action if you manage to collect
it locate the nearest respawn beacon and
call them back into the fight it's a
mechanic that's a direct response to the
perma death of its peers and reinforces
response team first mantra amongst
randoms the big surprise is gonna be
responding we couldn't make banner Alvin
didn't respond it just doesn't make
sense
respawn also iterated on the intricacies
of pub G in regards to inventory
management attachments and ammo types by
color-coding everything and simplifying
the knowledge of what goes with what how
everything works with the weapon
attachments dropping ammunition frog
it's incredible it might be the best
I've ever seen in any battle royale all
of these contextual tweaks and
iterations to a popular genre creates
the feeling of it's okay to sunk while
simultaneously providing a hardcore
experience built on foundational and
digestible mechanics
on top of these minor quality of life
changes respawn also managed to generate
those so simple yet effective moments
that every gamer pines for oh the smart
ping system as respawn calls it feels
like it's been there since the beginning
when in reality it's a system new to the
genre I like the way the apex has as
said hey okay you guys are all you all
have this thing that you're doing that's
great and I know we all enjoy your be
ours so what about this extra thing and
the speed at which epic said yeah we'll
take that put it in our game I think
that says a lot about about every other
BR and how they're all kind of feeding
off each other and this has been a thing
for forever man and it's already changed
the landscape of the Battle Royale genre
thank you for seeing that in Apex
because it was so good the rebel studio
with a penchant for bucking trends
entered and disrupted a popular
landscape while sacrificing the best
parts of their past in the name of
balanced gameplay we prototype
approximately a bajillion ways of having
Titans in this game and the reality was
they were an incredible unbalancing
factor and that goes back to the goals
of titans from titanfall 1 or 2 they
were meant to be a giant powerup for a
period of time whereas Federale games
but specifically apex legends are trying
to be much more level playing field
because apex dropped into a space with
already established parameters and
expectations respawn skipped arbitrary
explanations and gave players a product
they inherently understand while
delivering an experience whole unique -
response development history for us we
don't put it in a game unless we think
it fits and makes the game better in its
first eight hours apex legends racked up
a million unique players the next day
that number jumped to 2.5 a month after
release and apex hit a unique player
count of 50 million it's the first
contender to seriously challenge for the
twitch throne I think the game is a very
good game that has a lot of future
potential and is
could be a mainstay in the matter Royale
genre if things develop smoothly with
the game between February 4th when it
launched to March 5th apex averaged over
190,000 viewers to fortnight's roughly
126 thousand while watch time measured
137 million hours to fortnight's 91
million so there's a lot of people that
were very big in fortnight King Richard
is a good example and that we're like
fully dedicated to fortnight apex came
out and both him the man is just crying
the game like crazy he's pulling
thousands of viewers now it's great to
see that kind of dedication I think that
should tell people a lot about what
really the game has to offer and that's
quite a bit it is a very fast-paced be
our apex briefly knocked for tonight out
of the top spot on Twitch and the two
titles have been trading back and forth
for battle royale supremacy I think base
we're gonna take over for tonight
let's see stay down I feel like I feel
like apex as a game there's a lot more
solid a lot more fluid it feels better
it plays better than everything before
tonight is just got like it's got like
it's got the kids went over and it's got
the but it's not like the crowd
a success indicator for apex legends is
the fact that the streamers who respawn
partnered with are still playing the
game after their sponsored streams are
over I got paid to promote the game
yesterday but now I'm just playing it
because I like it and respawn is
supporting apex legends from an eSports
perspective right out of the gate while
other battle Royales have languished in
supporting the competitive community
it's absolutely amazing
respawn yeah everybody like it is a
beautiful beautiful game and I'm excited
to see what these streamers got he's
tied his all-time all-time high of today
thus far dizzy
Kings Canyon I think they just took the
lead hello and welcome to the wonderful
t1 and faced at Apex legends
Invitational any damage that can be done
and they apply a lot of pressure no
cover for these young chaps I'm afraid
down they go absolutely bamboozle here
that you are the new kill leader no
surprise here some of the world's best
apex Legends players on the screens
right now they will not be winning the
overall competition if they drop at this
stage they needed 28 kills and the
victory all come down and that's it it
will be decided
this is CodeRed Apex legends and then
those close to bleeding out he is so
close to bleeding out right now and
pushing forward good connects this is
what you need to do you need to isolate
out fight that's why he backed away to
heal up and now he's got the AR 301 out
is these on the chase for this next kill
yes we'll be able to clean that up but
he's left has a solo it just requires
that extra oomph to be able to dethrone
the kings of apex legend right now which
is happening with King Richard Mentos
and dizzy it's spark discussion from the
community in regards to the best format
to run successful competition the way
that these apex events are happening is
in public matches it's all about
killcount and the others there's way
down placement - and winning a game that
kind of thing but like it's very
engagement focused which is great that
makes for a fantastic battle royale
spectator experience if you're looking
at it from just a viewer standpoint
you're not weighing in you're not
variant bringing the you know the
competitor side of things in it's way
more fun to watch a game where everybody
is constantly pushing fights
everyone is it's always aggressive
gameplay because it's very action
focused after its launch players were
anticipating the release of a potential
battle past that most assumed Woodmere
fortnight season style format but when
wild frontier launched on march 19th
that anticipation turned to
disappointment so what I'm not what I'm
disappointed in is I'm not seeing enough
character skins it's all weapon skins
and I get that's what you see but I feel
like some people want to rock some cool
character skins respawn with there's
kind of fluid I feel like a lower tier
of content in there people were hoping
for a little bit it couples a few more
special things wild frontier felt like a
reactionary move rather than a decision
that would push apex legends in a unique
direction it's quickly it's quickly
evaporating I don't I don't think see a
season passes is gonna just like
absolutely take it to the next level no
I think it's just gonna maintain instead
of twisting the battle pass concept in
interesting ways
respawn served up the status quo
releasing a battle pass for the sake of
saying hey we have one too instead of
convincing players that the game was
going to be great during a months-long
lead-up to the release
respawn let Apex speak for itself the
best part about apex legends it's not
just free-to-play it's available right
now
if apex legend showed the video game
industry what could be accomplished with
smart influence or marketing and a
strong belief in product which is the
platform that allowed that message to
spread
three of them with it was that one all
that all day in an interview with Game
Informer lead producer drew McCoy sent
the decision to make Apex legends and
keep quiet about its release was
respawns at one point having to convince
EA this was the game to make apex
Legends is a perfect distillation of the
mythic overnight success that does not
exist but is used to describe a popular
trend this game is big and you know I'm
still liking it
be cool nuts you never know what games
blow up nowadays man you not I mean
this game is not $60 this game is
respawn has released fantastic
videogames years before apex Legends was
ever an idea but the ubiquitous
adoration afforded to the likes of
fortnight and epic games has always been
just out of reach what for Knight has
done for all battery outs and for what
they're gonna continue to do with
because they're still light years ahead
of any any other battery I'll with what
they've been doing for the last year
but what fortnight did they when they
came out with their game they they took
and they saw what what everyone's main
issues were with other Battle Royale
Zara previously out and then the camel
for Knight important he just killed it
in it in it amazing and it's definitely
one of the best girls for a long time
and while we can't know how apex legends
is going to net out in the long run all
eyes are focused on the rebel studio and
its spiritual successor to an embattled
franchise it's a game that brings
polished to a genre rife with jank while
adding small but thoughtful additions to
the sandbox that pushes the Battle
Royale landscape in an objectively
positive direction
respawn knocked it out of the park and I
still think they're mapping it bigger
put more players in it and still keep
the same philosophy of dead space I'm
telling you right now that is a triple-a
multi-million dollar app design idea
apex legends never showed off the fun we
were about to have you just handed us
the controller and step back excited
ready to watch the world react
[Music]
[Applause]
oh he's tied his all time an all-time
high of today thus far masses followed
with the mass if that's night
that's the champion
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]